great to see thanks for joining us on
the program this morning i'm sure you've
not had much sleep uh overnight
crunching all these numbers but given
that uh ones worth we're just hearing
second lowest council tax in the country
westminster lowest council tax in the
country they've both gone labour it's
not about the cost of living is it so
what's it about
well of course we've had some difficult
results and you've seen that in uh those
places in london i would say though
actually if you look across the country
we've made gains in places like hartley
paul we've made them in thorac we've
made them in in uneaten and actually
given that we're mid-term i think it
really doesn't show that labour have the
momentum to form the next government but
inevitably midterm we are going to have
challenges like this what's it down to
that you've lost these two
prime council seats in in the capital
including the palace of westminster is
in westminster council
well i i think it's worth looking at the
two of them so first of all in relation
to wandsworth uh we only won that by
about 200 votes last time round it was
an unexpected hole there is a general
momentum across london which you you've
seen here and you saw actually in the
past 20 years worth of elections in was
worth of us doing less well but of
course as as john said in his intro to
this piece there have been challenging
headlines for the past few months but i
do think that set against all of that
those sort of challenges that you would
expect after 12 years in office these
are a challenging result but we have
have made progress in lots of places so
it has to be viewed in that context okay
this is what the outgoing leader of
wandsworth council said
yes it did come up i'm not denying that
that didn't come i mean the the mr
parish's watching of television
of porn on his phone came up several
times i think there were a number of
people picking up different things that
they were concerned about and that came
up on the doorstep
party gate tractor gate
yes well of course there have been lots
of difficult headlines for the past few
months and i suppose okay that's the the
point that i'm making that if you set
that
these results against those difficult
headlines and if you set them against
the fact that we've been in power for
the past 12 years we're really not
seeing the kind of results so you saw
two years before 97 that blair victory
that was 1800 seats worth of gains for
the labour party william hague i think
gained about 1300 in 2000 and then went
on to lose the 2001 election so i of
course accept that these are challenging
times and there have been some difficult
results however i do not accept that
labour have the momentum to form the
next government of course we now in
response to that as a government need to
make sure that we really focus not on
those kind of headlines in the way that
the leader was describing but on what
matters to people whether that is
tackling the cost of living but that's
clearing those nhs backlogs or taking
advantage of the opportunities given us
by leaving the european union or perhaps
getting rid of the leader i mean you've
got three mps i think in the uh cumbria
carlisle
area and this is what the leader of
carlisle council has had to say
i've never been a fan of boris johnson
anyway
i've never made any great secrets of
that fact
and i think
i think he should consider his position
now and i fully expect that there will
be
more letters to the chairman of the
uh 22 committee
yep labour won the new uh council of
cumberland which will take in color
but time to the boss down to the boss
again but what i think and i i have have
great uh respect for him but he himself
admitted that he was never the biggest
fan of the the prime minister actually i
think that what you see in the prime
minister is somebody who gets things
done a change maker and whether that's
in relation to the vaccine program
fastest vaccine roll out
three times over or what he's been doing
in ukraine we need that kind of bold
leadership and i think precisely at a
time when we're facing these big
challenges whether it's costs of living
whether it's ukraine whether it's the
economic situation around the world that
you heard the basketball that you heard
in the past uh past 24 hours i think we
need somebody that can really grip
things and deliver that change and i
think that's what we've got in boris
johnson well the leader of the
conservatives in scotland of course uh
didn't agree this is what he said uh
previously i think what we've seen over
the last few days is more and more mps
uh publicly
saying they take a similar position to
me and there's a feeling that we're
getting closer and closer to the 54
number of letters required to go into
the 1922 committee he said that back in
january he was pressurized he
subsequently retracted that but that's
one of your own saying he's not the
right man for the job well i've actually
obviously as you might imagine i was
campaigning up in in scotland and i i
met with douglas while i was up there
and as you say he has that's not his
view now and i think he accepts as
indeed most people
that i spoke to
touring the length and breadth of the
country
they recognize what boris johnson has
done during this ukraine crisis the kind
of leadership he's shown they recognize
actually the leadership that he showed
during the the covid crisis with driving
that vaccine role and of course people
remember that he delivered brexit as he
promised and that's the kind of
focus and energy that that we need and i
think that's what he brings i'm glad you
brought brexit up because where are we
going to be in northern ireland they
start
counting in about 45 minutes time or
something like that
if shin fein takes power we could find
ourselves in a position
where boris johnson is the prime
minister who oversees the breakup of the
union
well first of all let's let's wait and
see what the results are from northern
ireland that's what all the projects and
well
i i hope you appreciate that we will
know that in in 24 hours you you rightly
highlight the provisions of the the
peace agreements there which do provide
that if there's a sustained uh majority
nationalist
opinion in in favor of uh united ireland
that that would have to be put forward
in a a referendum that's that's kind of
beyond the power of of the united
kingdom government in that sense we'd
have to allow that to happen where it
the case but let's wait and see what
happens yeah let's let's just remind our
viewers what it actually says the uh
northern ireland agreement a crucial
component to was the provision for a a
border pole committing both governments
in an internationally binding agreement
to legislate for reunification if a
simple majority of northern ireland's
electorate voted in favor that could be
um a reality if shin fein wins that must
make boris johnson's blood run cold this
morning
well boris johnson is as i am and the
entire cabinet we're passionate
unionists and we believe in the value of
northern ireland as part of our united
kingdom of course
we would honour the provisions of the
good friday agreement if that was a
required but i'm confident that we will
be able to make the case for northern
ireland remaining in the united kingdom
should that uh that arise but i don't
think we're at that stage left so that
let's not be within 12 hours well let's
let's wait george used to sat just where
you are earlier on this week and said
that the british government would step
in to prevent that happening that's not
going to happen is it if endangering
fein wins and we do press towards a
border referendum the british government
would allow that to happen wouldn't they
well the british government will respect
its uh treaty obligations including in
the the good friday agreement but i
don't think we're we're anywhere near
that so joshua's just misspoke when he
said that earlier in the week well i'm
afraid i didn't hear exactly what george
used to said but i'm very clear that we
will respect our international
obligations but as i say i don't think
we are we are close to invoking the
provisions of that yeah as i said i'll
let me put that to you again
this prime minister could be the prime
minister that oversees the splitting up
of the union if that were to happen with
northern ireland all eyes would be
towards scotland
well kay i think you're you're jumping
many steps ahead here
so first of all we don't know the
results in in northern ireland and in
any event uh we have the provisions of
that
treaty
i'm absolutely confident that the people
of northern ireland
as has been shown on many occasions
before would choose to remain within the
united kingdom so i don't actually think
that that eventuality will arise well
we'll see as you said um whatever
happens in the next 12 hours even if
sinn fein does win in northern ireland
we see what happens in wales
and also up in scotland where you're not
likely to do very well whatever happens
you still feel that boyce johnson is the
right man to lead your party
well i think looking at the the picture
of the results so far they demonstrate
that whilst there have been difficult
results they are consistent with what
you'd expect with us from mid-term
labour are certainly not on the path to
power and i believe that boris johnson
does have the leadership skills in
particular the energy and the dynamism
that we need during this difficult
period of time so no i don't think we
should uh removed boris johnson as our
prime minister i think we should stick
with him i think he's got the skills we
need to lead us into the next okay what
happens uh if it transpires in the
coming weeks which it's likely to that
he's broken the law on more than uh one
occasion and as a result has misled
parliament would he still be the right
man for the job
well may i take each one of those in in
turnkey first of all
you'll expect me to say but i'll have to
say it which is i'm not going to indulge
in hypotheticals it is right as a
cabinet minister i allow the police to
do their job i don't actually believe
that he misled parliament i think he
gave a very clear explanation of that
and what what he said at the time in
parliament
he genuinely believed to be the case and
i think taking into account all of these
things and by the way i've i've been
clear on this show and many others i
don't for a moment resile from my anger
and frustration about what happened in
downing street and i think the prime
minister has shown a rightly shown
remorse over that and he feels a
frustration about it as well i have
accepted what he said in respect to that
because i believe that we need to
balance that against his considerable
achievements which i've already outlined
to you and the need for the energy and
dynamism to lead this country forward
and i believe that he has that do you
want my viewers who are watching this
morning to honestly believe that this
man presided over
the biggest rule breaking in the whole
of the country in one street and he
didn't know what was happening under his
own roof because obviously the
electorate doesn't think that
well
first of all i think the prime minister
has given an explanation of that and
there's not a great deal that i i can
add to i thought it was a very clear
expression i think many of your viewers
and i certainly found this when i was
speaking people do
recognize and acknowledge the
considerable achievements of the united
kingdom government led by boris johnson
in getting the vaccine program that's
i think you you'll also see
that uh if if you look for example the
decision that we took to keep the
economy open i remember in the run-up to
christmas starmer drakeford sturgeon
many elements of the media i should say
actually not sky news we're demanding
that we shut the economy back down the
prime minister made the very difficult
call to keep the economy open which
means we have
unemployment falling
we have strong growth
and i think people recognize those
things now okay you you talk about the
the results and i have um
accepted that there are difficult
results in london but i do think that
those are more consistent with what you
would expect from a government
in mid-term in a battleground that is
dominated by urban areas that tend to
favor the
the the labour party and those results
uh as disappointed as i genuinely am
that we've lost excellent public
servants in both of those councils and
elsewhere i i think that those are
consistent with trends that you have
seen previously and not mr party china
we're almost at a change of government
yeah you see elsewhere mr polish we're
almost out of time i've illustrated to
you in some detail why when you have
lost seats that you you would you would
have thought that you wouldn't lose
boros in london westminster council
cheapest council tax in the whole of the
country they said it's because of boris
johnson i've illustrated to you that
boris johnson could be the prime
minister that oversees the breakup of
the union i've illustrated to you that
he could
undoubtedly find himself in a position
where he's going to get more fines from
the metropolitan police they gave him
the courtesy of waiting until after the
election in order before they issued
more fines and you're still sitting
there and telling our viewers this
morning this man can do no wrong
i'm not saying that this man can do do
no wrong and i've i've accepted the
considerable mistakes that were made in
downing street but i've also accepted
the explanation that he's given i've
highlighted uh the considerable
achievements he's had whether that's
with the vaccine program where that's
leading the world in our the democratic
world's response to the ukraine crisis
or whether that's in respect of getting
brexit done and i think when those
things are considered in the balance the
right thing is that as people are
worried about these challenges
caused by this global the
global challenges of both recovering
from covid and the pressure on inflation
ukraine crisis both national security
and the economy we need strong and clear
leadership and i think the boris johnson
delivers that okay it's good to talk to
you i must let you go
a busy round of media chats this morning
for you thank you for joining us on the
program mr chairman thank you